In this video, we'll explore Triangle Count with both LODs and Nanai.
Oftentimes, when using TCC tools that aren't designed for a real-time environment,
we can end up with very complex geometry.
Perhaps it's coming from a program like Revit where construction is the goal,
or 3ds Max where perhaps it's going to render with an offline tool such as V-Ray,
and therefore the size of the scene is not as important as it might be
in a real-time environment like Unreal Engine.
Be careful of the level of detail you actually need before you bring your assets into Unreal.
If we don't need to see every tread on a tire on a forklift, for example,
perhaps those tires could be simplified, similar when it comes to things like nuts, bolts, screws,
things that might be important for a manufacturing process,
but not necessarily for a real-time visualization of those products.
And yes, we will discuss Nanite where you can have millions of triangles at a time,
but for the moment, let's assume we're developing for a platform that does not support Nanite, like a mobile phone.
LODs stand for Level of Detail. Starting with LOD 0, we have the highest polyversion of this equipment,
going down to LOD 3 where we can see that it becomes simpler and simpler.
The idea of Levels of Detail is that you change the level of detail you're seeing
as you get further away from the object, meaning that something that is only taking up a few pixels on screen
will not be rendering at the same level that it would be if it is taking up most of your monitor.
There are a number of ways to generate LODs. You can do them, of course, in your DCC tool and import them.
You can do it manually in Unreal. We can set up the number of LODs we want,
change the triangle percentage, set up a few LOD groups, which already have certain settings for how they're set up,
and then we can even get into details related to screen size and when we switch from one LOD to another.
There's a handy Mesh LOD coloration mode in Unreal that allows us to visualize which LOD is active at any given moment.
Here in the LOD map, we have our forklift, and if we go to that visualization for Mesh LOD coloration,
we can see the color change as we zoom in and out, despite the fact that when we're in Lit Mode,
you really can't tell when we're switching from one LOD to another.
We can also see this visualized directly in the Static Mesh Editor window where we start with level 0,
and we go very quickly to level 1, 2, 3 as the screen size changes.
If we wanted to adjust any of this further, we could simply type in LOD, make this custom,
use however many LODs we want, then we could even do something like uncheck Auto Compute LOD Distances,
and then start to get very specific with the screen sizes that we swapped these two.
As a quick example of another adjustment we could make, let's go down to LOD Settings and add in a fifth LOD, hit Apply Changes,
and of course LOD 0 is 1, so we'll see a total of LOD 4,
but we won't see it until we say what screen size we should switch to it on.
So as we go .56, .42, maybe this one becomes .2.
And now 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, once we get to there as that screen size goes below 2.
And at any one of those we can also decimate it further and say actually when we're at .2,
I want to be at 20% triangles, and we could apply that.
Confirm we don't see too big of a difference, and now we're all the way down at less than 2,000 triangles.
If the platform you're targeting supports it, Nanite can be an excellent way to handle millions and millions of polygons
for your scene without hurting performance.
The basic way Nanite works is it's identifying what is visible on a pixel per pixel level for your project
and ensures not to draw more polygons than will actually be visible within that pixel.
Thus we can have something that started as 5.8 triangles as seen in the STAT RHI window in the top,
and then reduce that down to about 16,000 triangles just by enabling Nanite.
There's a number of different ways to enable Nanite.
You can right-click on an object, go to the Nanite window and change it there.
When we open up our static or skeletal mesh window, we can enable Nanite,
and yes, skeletal meshes are supported by Nanite well,
and yes, skeletal meshes are supported by Nanite as well, including trees and foliage now.
And when we're importing through the FBX Import Options dialog,
we also often have the option to generate a Nanite mesh at that time as well.
Always be sure to hit Apply Changes when you're done.
Otherwise, you won't see the change.
Let's go ahead and open up the Nanite map,
and we'll see we have a piece of geometry here where if we type STAT RHI,
it's 7 million, nearly 8 million triangles being drawn here with over 500 draw calls.
Pretty expensive.
Oh, and we have a few additional pieces of geometry as well.
So what we could do is find where these live.
Over here in Nanite, we have our different static meshes,
and I could simply right-click on all of these, tell them all to enable Nanite.
And then without changing anything about the complexity of the scene,
we now see we're drawing 13,000 polygons, and we're down to about 200 draw calls,
though that number is actually less because of all the other elements being drawn here in the editor.
If we'd like to visualize Nanite directly, we can go to Nanite Visualization Triangles
and see the sort of real-time, LOD pixel-level triangle adjustments happening
as we get closer and farther away.
No need to generate LODs.
Now, of course, many platforms don't support Nanite,
and Nanite can be a bit of a ram hog,
and of course, you have to package all these assets at their full quality,
so there's still a number of instances where a traditional LOD system might be best,
but there is something very satisfying about being able to get very close to geometry
and seeing as much detail as we can.
Thanks, Nanite.
In the next video, we'll look at the Unreal Engine modeling tools.